jetzt sieht es tatsächlich fest wir
menschen sind in der lage gezielt in die
evolution einzugreifen kaputte gene raus
aus dem körper gesunde gene rein und
schon ist die erbkrankheit bewegt oder
viel schlimmer wir bauen uns den super
menschen mit einer einfachen und
effektiven technik unvorstellbar doch
genau das ist jetzt ein us
wissenschaftlerteam an menschlichen
embryonen gelungen was für die einen
die erfolgsmeldung überhaupt ist ist
für die anderen einfach nur
unverantwortlich auch man erbkrankheiten
jetzt teilen kann und ob es schon bald
designerbabys geben wird jetzt in
science fiction herzlich willkommen
die idee für designer babys die schon
länger doch bislang gibt es nicht nur
ethische bedenken wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen waren bisher der
meinung dass die forschung noch nicht
weit genug sei die technik noch nicht
genügend ausgereift und zu
fehleranfällig dafür um sie
tatsächlich an menschen auszuprobieren
wir haben ja hier über die probleme
berichtet doch jetzt ist die idee der
designer babys prast realität geworden
es fehlt eigentlich nur noch ein kleiner
schritt bei dem experiment der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus portman ging es konkret um die
lebensgefährliche herzmuskelschwäche
hypertrophe kardiomyopathie bei der der
herzmuskel an einer weise so sie kann
wächst dass er nicht mehr in der lage
ist das blut effizient in den
blutkreislauf zu pumpen und die
erbkrankheit ist gar nicht so selten
einer von 500 menschen ist getroffen und
in etwa 40 prozent ist das gnm y b p3
auf chromosom 11 notiert und somit klar
als ursachen zu benehmen wenn ein
elternteil diese mutation im erbgut
bewegt liegt das risiko dass die kinder
auch mit der besagten
herzmuskelschwäche geboren werden bei
50 prozent bei ihrem experiment nutzen
die forscherinnen und forscher die
sogenannte griff bacav 19
manchmal auch als das neue als werkzeug
der gentechnik benannt mit dieser
methode lassen sich ausgewählte gene
einfügen ausschalten oder auch
umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach
funktioniert ganz simpel wie eine schere
mit ihr kann die dna das erbgut ziemlich
effektiv verändert werden
das forscherteam aus portman befruchtete
in ihrem versuch gesunde eizellen von
menschen mit spermien eines bänder sehr
an eben dieser beschriebenen
herzmuskelschwäche liegt doch die
spritze nicht nur die spermien soll man
eben auch entsprechende griff beim
portier in die einzel
diese sollten den kaputten abschnitt der
die erbkrankheit auslöst ausschneiden
und durch einen gesunden abschnitt
ersetzen und tatsächlich in 42 von 58
millionen war der defekt behoben die
herzmuskelschwäche hatte sich also
durch den einsatz der körper methode
nicht mehr auf die hälfte
und übertragen sondern nur noch auf
knapp ein drittel ein ergebnis das viele
in der wissenschaftswelt den atem
anhalten lässt doch der versuch hat
auch schwächen die zahl der versuchs
embryo ist eher klein das ergebnis
deswegen nicht unbedingt aussagekräftig
zudem ist etwas seltsames passiert und
das können die forscherinnen und
forscher einfach nicht erklären
nicht der künstliche dna schnipsel der
christa proteine wo wir in die embryos
eingebaut sondern der gesunde schnitzel
aus der natürlichen eizelle der
eigentlich als kopiervorlage zur
reparatur dient zugespitzt formuliert
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wissen nicht was sie da
getan haben offen bleibt zudem ob die
technik auch einsetzbar wäre wenn der
gendefekt sowohl väterlicher weit als
auch mütterlicherseits existieren
würde dennoch ist das ergebnis von
großer bedeutung bisher wurden erst
drei vergleichbare studien
veröffentlicht ein ähnlicher versuch
chinesischer wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler musste frühzeitig
abgebrochen werden es gab zu viele
ungeplante gehen veränderungen die
ungeahnte konsequenzen mit sich hätten
bringen können den tod der embryos
fehlbildung krebs oder andere erkrankung
wenn das ist das riesige problem von
chris zu viel geht im wahrsten sinne des
wortes dann eben zu viel wird auch an
anderen stellen des erbgutes verändert
und das zum teil ziemlich unkontrolliert
wie wir ja berichtet haben dennoch ist
das ergebnis und auch der gesamte
forschungszweig von großer bedeutung
denn bislang sind mehr als 10.000
erbkrankheiten bekannt bei denen ein
elternteil defekte gene an ihre kinder
weitergeben und nur die wenigsten dieser
krankheiten will zu behandeln oder gar
zu heilen frauen mit kinderwunsch
könnten zudem auf eine weitere
hormonbehandlung verzichten da sich
durch diese methode die zahl der
brauchbaren also brauchbaren embryonen
nach einer künstlichen befruchtung
deutlich steigern ließe der versuch des
us forscherteam zeigt jedenfalls dass
gentechnisch modifizierte kinder keine
zukunftsmusik mehr sind sondern
wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der
zeit
zeit in der es kaum gehen wird das
risiko für nebenwirkungen so weit zu
senken
es ist irgendwann tatsächlich einfach
mal ein experimentierfreudiger forscher
ausprobieren aber keine angenehme
vorstellung völlig unbeeindruckt davon
was gesundheitsbehörden und
ethikkommissionen für angemessen halten
und wie weit die diskussion darüber
fortgeschritten ist ob es erlaubt sein
sollte erbgut vor der geburt so zu
bearbeiten wie sich mediziner oder
eltern wünschen dabei ist es noch mehr
als unklar was sollte ein
unwiderruflicher eingriff in das
menschliche erbgut und damit auch wenn
die evolution für konsequenzen haben
könnte langfristigen nebenwirkungen die
vielleicht erst unsere enkel bemerken
und auch ganz absurde dinge wären
möglich wenn wir wirklich das erbgut
verändern könnte es könnten super
menschen als soldaten gezüchtet werden
und das auch noch super einfach das ist
schon eine gespenstische perspektive und
wenn man sich da so manches totalitäre
regime vorstellt ist es nicht völlig
unwahrscheinlich
das wird auch getan wird wenn es
möglich ist über xing hat ihr euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden was das
thema angeht wenn ihr kein video dazu
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
bakterien als datenspeicher
da geht es um die extremen
möglichkeiten begriff backert 9 bietet
absolut irre und gefährlich also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken und ansonsten
besand bleibt dran